- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is you have to diversify.
Over to you, Kevin O'Leary.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- Diversification, what
I've learned that works
if you're an investor no matter
how much money you've got
whether it's $5000 or 500 million,
diversification is what
saves you from disaster.
Having investments in a
wide range of businesses
and sectors,
there's always something working
when something else isn't.
So today, I can go to bed tonight
knowing that I have one objective.
I want to go to bed richer than I woke up
and the only way that's
going to happen to me
is to be invested in a
lot of different things
'cause every day, one thing
works while three others don't
but sometimes that's why you get richer.
- This is the first entspresso
that I've had hard time with
and I'm wondering if I
actually agree with it or not.
I get how it works.
When you're invested in stocks,
you don't want to have
more than 5% of your money
into one stock because
if something happens
then you could lose a lot of your money
but I'm not sure that applies
to the rest of your life
and any idea, right?
He said don't invest
more than 5% in any idea
and I think as an entrepreneur,
it's easy to spread yourself too thinly
and you should go all in on
the idea that you love most.
If you only invest 5% of your
time or money into an idea,
that means you're running
at least 20 different ideas
at the same time.
That's crazy to me.
That sounds like a
disaster waiting to happen
and again, spreading yourself so thinly
that you can't get anything done.
Instead, you're doing a lot
of stuff in a mediocre way
instead of one thing
really really really well.
I'm a big believer in
betting on your strengths
and when you find it and
that thing that you love
and you're passionate about
it, you go all in on it
and I'm a fan of Andrew Carnegie
who became the richest man in the world
and he said, in opposite
of diversification,
he said, put all your eggs in one basket
and then watch that basket.
So we've got a couple
different views on this one.
One says diversify like crazy.
One says go all in on one thing.
I'm really curious to find
out what you guys think.
So that's my question of the day for you.
How much do you believe
in diversification for your business?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
Thank you so much for watching.
Have an amazing day.
Continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going